in an interview with CBS this morning
Democratic presidential candidate Andrew
yang says he is confident he can defeat
frontrunner Joe Biden right now the
businessman is polling at about two to
four percent nationwide but 2020 hopeful
told us why he believes he has what it
will take to beat President Trump polls
show that most Democratic voters and
Democratic leaning independents
two-thirds the main thing they wanted a
candidate is someone who can beat Donald
Trump yep yes I'm one of only two
candidates in the field that 10% or more
of Donald Trump voters say that they
would support why is that it's because
I'm focused on solving the problems that
they see around them every day and I'm
laser focused on trying to make their
lives better that's why I'm getting
thousands of Trump voters as well as
independents and libertarians and
Democrats and progressives if I'm the
Democratic nominee we win that's the
math that's Joe Biden's argument too
well that's one reason why he's leading
in the polls and that's one reason
you'll see me leading in the polls
before too long you think you can beat
Joe Biden I think I'll be the nominee if
you listen to Joe talk about it his main
argument is that his election is going
to be a restoration of the obama-biden
administration yeah in essence which is
a move literally backwards in time and
so to me saying that we can somehow a
race not just Donald Trump the
presidency but all of the reasons why
people voted for Donald Trump to me is
not correct I mean you know these things
have happened and we're going to have to
address them gonna have to solve the
problems I got Donald Trump elected one
if we're gonna win and two if we're
gonna move the country forward it's
interesting yang is appealing to trump
voters in a lot of ways because he's
also painting a fairly dark picture of
the direction of the economy but he's
saying the solution the problem isn't
immigration it's automation and he's the
candidate who's offering $1,000 a month
a freedom dividend he calls it to
everybody in the country essentially and
he's he's he's sort of carved out his
face no one else has freedom dividend is
a good name and $1,000 a month is a good
policy it's it's pretty attractive